my name is brittany peterson
b-r-i-t-t-a-n-y
peterson p-e-t-r-s-o-n and i have
a first grader and a second grader
perfect and so tell me a little bit are
you feeling nervous now that the kids
are gonna go back to school or
uh you know there's a whole lot of
commotion you know parents are for it
parents are against it
where do you stand and what are you
feeling right now
so i feel as though the children should
return
um i am nervous and anxious for my kids
to return
i feel nervous for the teachers and the
staff i know that they're working
tirelessly to try and
initiate a plan um one of my friends
was mentioning she's a teacher and an
administrator and she
was mentioning that it has taken her
several hours
over the weekend to distribute like
specials and so i just feel for them and
i know that they are working hard to get
this
up and running but i do feel like it's a
benefit to the children to return
and my kids have struggled mentally
and they have i mean i feel like we have
a pretty good home life and
they're pretty lucky in the wider
spectrum of this i feel like a lot of
children are struggling with mental
illness
and it's something that isn't spoken
about and for a long time
i didn't realize that i had mental
illness and i do struggle with mental
illness
and with this i feel like it is creating
a trajectory of
mental illness in children and making
this
issue more apparent in kids at younger
ages
john evans uh first name is john john
last name is emmons e-m-m-o-n-s
uh my kids i've got a
kid in pre-k uh one kid in first grade
and another kid in sixth grade perfect
so uh tell me will you be sending your
kids back to school
come march first no we won't be doing
that
and what do you feel with the whole
situation or how are you feeling about
the whole situation i should say
uh we're cautious um our concern right
now is that
uh the schools uh
have a lot of challenges before them um
and then
there's a lot of people out there in the
world that aren't taking this seriously
and they have kids um and we just have
to make sure that uh we protect our own
since we have two
or technically three people in the
danger demographic that live in this
house
perfect and as far as just maybe some of
the things that maybe you like to see
from the district now that they're
getting ready to you know start this new
challenge or or see this new new change
come
march 1st where they're going to allow
pre-k students the third grade
students to go back to the classroom um
is there anything that you
as a parent would like to see or would
like to know that they're doing
yeah um i think that they're trying to
communicate really well
i do know i mean my wife is a teacher i
have permission to say this so
she said you know she would like clear
communication
as to what's happening she still doesn't
know exactly what's happening
come march first and it is february 15th
or 16th
today so she's concerned
um because she should be planning for
that um and that's a concern
you